hi everyone Sal Khan here from Khan
Academy and I'm here with Mark richer
who is director of product management
and Android at Google to talk a little
bit about device security so a mark
welcome and my my first question is what
is device security are we talking about
somehow keeping our mobile devices
secure
we are talking about that we're trying
to say how do you make sure your device
your mobile phone your tablet anything
that's digital these days is guarded
against you know unwanted access that
could be coming from you know hackers in
some other country it could be coming
from someone in the room next door in
all cases we want to give you the right
level of protection and security
and I just want to make this tangible
for folks because I think we all have a
sense that okay you know that we don't
want people messing around on our phones
or on our tablets or our laptops but
when has device security not gone well
for folks
there's more and more information on
these devices you know we trust them
with not just whatever the application
itself is asking us but often it knows
where you are in the world your location
it knows what you've typed in and what
you've searched and knows whom you're
communicating with all these different
dimensions you know they can be
exploited uh for the most part good
things are happening and I'm definitely
an optimist in this space but we want to
make sure that people understand what's
going on understand who has access to
the information and then they can make
the appropriate decisions and trade-offs
so that they get the right level of
control without sacrificing all that's
really cool about you know technology I
really tried not to to frighten people
but to say you know what could happen
What could happen if all of your local
education information were out there is
you know on a Continuum from it could be
embarrassing to bad things could happen
in the real world if someone knows
exactly where you're going to be at a
given time to they cross correlate that
information with something else and they
use that to maybe send you a scam send
you a phishing warning send you you know
some sort of crime could take place
there really is quite a breath and you
know unfortunately these criminals are
very motivated and they're seeing
positive results so they do keep
innovating and that's again why we want
people to have that right level of
protection that right level of control
over their sensitive data on their
devices yeah one of the things that
immediately comes into mind in other
videos we've produced we talk about how
two-factor authentication is really
important because for someone to be able
to get access to your password and your
device is very unlikely but to your
point if they do get access to your
device or if they're able to track your
movements in some way they might be be
able to fake being you a little bit
better and get access to all sorts of
things or pretend to be you and
embarrass you at minimum or or do worse
access to your bank accounts Etc yeah
that's actually the one that I'm even
more scared of you know people might say
you know I don't do anything suspicious
I don't do anything risky what do I care
the problem is that then what the
attackers want to do is leverage your
reputation to go after someone else and
that can be terrible you know some of
you may have seen what we call the the
mugged in London scam you get a message
that looks like it's from your uncle or
your cousin or your grandmother or what
have you saying I've been attacked
please wire money to me and this is a
scam it's coming from the attackers who
broke into that person's account and
then sent it to all their family members
so again even if you're not worried that
you yourself have sensitive data what
you really don't want is somebody taking
your reputation and using that to
bootstrap their way into even more
heinous crimes wow that's so powerful I
could imagine if someone close to me
texted me right now and said that I'd be
like oh yeah
it's a good good word of warning and
then you know both parties feel guilty
about that it's terrible in all around
it's really this awful exploitation
okay whether or not you intended you you
scared me a little bit which I think is
good but there's hope there's hope we
can work together so